HIS HIRED LINE MATCHING UP THEH.
MAYBYB ONCE AGAINY.
THINKING AB
SHOOTING.
DIDN'T.
NOW IFECTIVE.
THEY WANT THE PUCK BACK.D.
MATTHIAS EKHOLM COUNCE ON A SHAP
>> Harnarayan: THE POWER PLAY
PROWESS CONTINUES THANKS TO LEON
DRAISAITL!HINGS UP
WITH A BEAUTIFUL PASS BACK TO
THE HIGHH
DUCHENE LOOKING TO RETURN  RIPP
ONE.
PICKS HIS SPOT.
BEATS KOS
EVIDENT ON THIS SH GO RIGHT
AROUND.
CARRIER DRIVE TO THE NET AND
FIND H H COUPLE
NIGHTS AGO.
REAL BIG ONES..
[Horn sounds]
THROUGH.
ONE WAS TRIPPED WIDE INTO THE
CORNER.
FOEGELE, BATTLING FOR IT PRESSU
KOSKINEN AND COMES UP WITH BIGR.
AND HE SAW IT THE
KAILER YAMAMOTO's GOING TO SKATE
FAKE, A PASS.
NUGENT-HOPKINS A PASS TH
IN
NASHVILLE HAS POSSESSION OF THE
PUCK.
QUICK SHOT.
>> Louie: QUICK START FOR THE
NASHVILLE PREDATORS GET THAT
CHANCE OUT OF THE GATESHOOTS.
SCORES!
[Horn sounds]
HE PICKS HIS SPOT.
SO MUCH ATTENTION TO McDAVID.N!
[Horn sounds]IN.
STEALS THIS PUCK FROM DUCHENE.
AND JUSTT
NASHVILLE TRYING TO GET BACK
INTO THIST LITTLE REDIRECTION.
OILERS ON THE COMES RYAN NUGENT.
TWO-ON-ONE WITH ZACH HYMAN.
NUGENT-HOPKINS A PAPA
THE PREDATORS ARE
LINE.
LITTLE FLARE PUCK.
AND BOUCHARD UP TO DRAISAITL.
HE'S GOT TWO